[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lorsque nous serons la fin de notre
Agge quand les nouveaux temps passent vers le Sud
nous
visages et que temps d'hiver
blanchissons-nous
Cheveux quand je rév Encore que dans tes
yeux lorsque nous en serons cette joie
de
vivre o nous serons heureux simplement
survivre même à un jour encore en avance
de quoi
partage nous partage Tous deux un regard
un
sourire dans La Maison fanée
sans temoins sans
personnen nous verrons ses
feuillet notre dernier
automne le soir la
veillée us curs pleins de
tendresse nous rêver Au
passé sans regret sans
tristesse lorsque nous ne serons que de
ven
hésitant quand nous Ne saurons Plus que
deux ombres
tremblant lorsque nos mains ridai dans
un denier
[Musique]
effort pour Ne Plus se quitter se
chercher
Encore lorsque nous en serons la fin de
l'histoire ou le présent
Je suis parti
moo lorsque nous n'auront Plus pour
Unique à venir
que l'espace d'un rêve les temps d'un
Souvenir danois
La maison
fanée sans témoins sans personne nous
voir ses
feuillet notre dernier
automne l'un près de l'autre assis comme
dans cet instantané
mme
Je te
dire
Merci Je te
dis hein
[Musique]
t'aimes